[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça fait vraiment plaisir d'avoir des
amis à la maison
ça c'est
là bas
fait dix minutes dissensions
et bien un silence de mort
[Musique]
oui
à ce taper
aa
toujours bonjour snapper snap bonjour
type stocker tilt opus bonjour un sac
rappeur offre et verbeuse bonjour
chômeurs chômeuses bonjour à tout le
monde et j'ai tiguan dit voilà on signe
la 406 d'accord pour mon ami 30 l'accord
qui a un magasin à lyon et qui qui
collectionne les voitures des films
voilà c'est le spécialiste de toutes les
voitures la batman
retour vers le futur 406 et autres j'en
passe et des meilleurs donc on dédicaces
30 voitures pour moi
série limitée le taxi avec l'autographe
du pilote
est-ce qu'on
it's raining